Okay, so this is what I wrote. The document
object model stores data about the content of a page
and the properties of each note word. To build the
DOM, the browser parses HTML and creates tokens from HTML
tags. Some tokens indicate a tag start, others indicate a
tag end. The tokens are converted into node objects, forming
a tree structure, which we call the DOM. The relationships
between objects in the DOM tells us which ones are
parents and which ones are children. It's also worth noting that
DOM construction is incremental, which means that we can start building the
DOM as soon as we have the HTML and we don`t
need to wait for the entire HTML page to start building it.